si es la ausencia de estructura
foto a un lado en el departamento de South Tracy
fueron muri rent rus
estricto edificio público cerrado si
fundas escolares josé alquilalas a un no ai
saldo para malcolm tal pero la estimación
imprimaciones podemos para compartimentos lassen
losas de extraño socialismo inmerso
dario y nassi lekaj
particularmente que es para la tarde del sur
admas gran importancia económica y la
iti
deja caer a john e
habríamos tenido dificultades para sostener ste
país en cuanto a
infraestructura aunque como henry operaba
su autoridad y fuego en el frente
situación como r operó un gillo
servicio de emergencia para esperar en
persona que está de pie y de daspo que escudos de armas
con la limpieza de la simplificación
cansado el chat es tiempo domesticado para uno
reacción como tal la protección civil
estaba móvil mobilizing sousse recursos
pero es el primer ministro ariel d alunzio
che todo el buen año estamos movilizados
por ahora tono suave recursos de su
la administración hará le dará a las víctimas y
gorjeo
en simpatía por los padres de la ciudad
valdes violento terremoto de como sueños
a mano a lai espíritu de solidaridad ed
dicho compromiso conoce el plan para
un aire roto seguirá siendo dramático
situación de en memoria gritos y su
grandes funcionarios haitianos que el propio sindicato
fuerza estrés encontrará un
terremoto devastador muy fuerte
en el año 2000 dan buena parte
de la capital la acción del puerto
principe que leccion de decoro y estancia
emergencia es que se puede razonar un
mitigar un poco el impacto de esto
nuevo terremoto que eres punto común
estamos informando
bueno y ahora sientes que es año
Mosley
en un
movimiento de la feria sin embargo el problema
cierto el curso es tu problema
assen que ahora no hay comida imos prestados
advierte que el problema del terremoto se ralentiza
di los medios asta ahora es el palacio
nacional de haiti y siempre es destino
de sus dioses mas dds alias
cultivo son barreras el estudiante salus
lo que esta haciendo es haiti y este momento
es la crisis politica y ahi esta
tratamiento y aumento de la pandemia y cómo 10
nuevos gags en oreste terremoto it ambiente
y en un poquito de aspo dria esta tocando la
tormenta tropical gracia el pais y aguanta
capaz del palacio se enfrentó permaneció
desde la junta internacional
convenció a la raza para que urgentemente por
que soy estrés múltiple escribieron
en clase y tom araya xian nu jazz
dificultad y sobre todo que pesar
aplicación privada de lipu de la línea seguro que
no menciono y la parte sobre el pais verde
verano con edad de la capital i por
ahora es mi desafio y sport pasa el
matisse barrio que es chocar con lo nuevo
puerto
grupos armados banda armada
informándole de su del puerto
principe muy gordo puede quedarse puertas
de la capital haitiana ge sta nor
valorando toros en los viejos ios que las castas
terremoto de 7.2